coronavirus dont on parlait à l'instant
alors que l'épidémie ne cesse de
s'étendre la planète finance prend peur
et des perspectives de croissance
mondiale sont revus à la baisse
face à la menace les banques centrales
sont à la manoeuvre sans pour autant
rassurer les marchés alors comment
l'expliquez une nouvelle crise
économique comparable à celle de 2008 et
elle à nos portes on voit ça tout de
suite avec l l'économiste jacques sapir
bonsoir bienvenue jacques merci
stéphanie alors jacques doit-on vraiment
craindre une crise économique provoquée
par cette épidémie c'est ce que beaucoup
de gens se pose comme question oui et il
est clair que les gouvernements comme
les opérateurs financiers ont pris
depuis quinze jours maintenant
simplement la mesure de ce qui est en
train de se passer
alors évidemment ça a eu des
conséquences importantes sur les bourses
mais pas que on a vu que le prix des
matières premières a aussi fortement
baissé en particulier le pétrole et
campsas expliqué bien globalement tout
le monde pensait que c'était une
épidémie comme celle du strass en 2003
sauf qu'en réalité le virus est beaucoup
plus contagieux que le virus du strass
on a dix fois plus de malades au moins
rien que pour la chine par ailleurs le
poids de la chine est beaucoup plus
important que ce qu'il était en 2003
donc tout concourt à faire que dans une
économie qui aujourd'hui est plus
fragile
en réalité qu'en 2003 et bien tout
concourt à ce que l'on ait une crise
mondiale
alors avant toute chose jacques âge vous
propose de regarder les réactions des
personnes que nous avons interrogé sur
les risques que fait peser ce virus on
est tous alerte à ce qui se passe
notamment sur les marchés boursiers on a
tous été alerte à la chute vertigineuse
des cotations américaine et dans une
moindre mesure européenne au niveau de
mes placements il ya eu une grosse
baisse puisque les marchés mondiaux ont
réagi la chine étant au coeur de
l'épidémie
c'est les marchés chinois qui ont
beaucoup baissé mais de manière générale
tous les marchés ont baissé tous les
émergents la première chose c'est de ne
pas paniquer parce qu'effectivement si
vous vendez vos actions et que demain
vos collègues vont des actions par
définition tout le monde va vendre ses
actions les vagues déplacements sont
très limités et à l'heure actuelle on
part donc des solutions telles que le
spécial ont des plans de continuité
d'activité pour travailler de chez nous
pour éviter la propagation du virus et
ses impacts sur tous les événements en
fait sur lesquels on doit participer en
france il ya un maximum d'événements qui
sont annulés nous ont battus revivra
tech en juin et on a peur que ça soit
annulée à cause du coût d'un viol je
pense pas que le corona virus peut être
à l'origine d'une d'une récession
globale de l'économie
ça peut être un élément déclencheur je
pense mais pas le facteur principal la
paranoïa peut provoquer la crise
économique peut doubler la crise
sanitaire d'une réelle crise économique
maintenant si la population continue à
garder ces mêmes habitudes économique à
maintenir son niveau de consommation la
donne ne devrait pas changer et je sais
déjà qu'il ya plusieurs entreprises qui
re qui se disent qu'ils vont peut-être
rapatrier les usines en france ou au
moins une partie de la production en
france en espagne ou en allemagne
justement parce que tout est bloqué en
chine pour une durée d'un indéterminée
c'est pour ça que je dis que c'est bien
aussi parce que ça fait que des grosses
entreprises commencent à se poser des
questions votre réaction jacques bien
c'est très intéressant parce que on voit
que les gens qui ont été interrogés ont
conscience qu'ils se passe quelque chose
alors après il attribue plus de poids au
marché chinois coc marchés occidentaux
le cac40 le dow jones et puis surtout il
ya une espèce comme toujours de
méconnaissance des chaînes de
propagation réel de cette crise alors
jacques il y a eu ces derniers jours un
mini krach est un boursier que s'est il
passé concrètement alors ce qui s'est
passé depuis maintenant à peu près une
quinzaine de jours c'est que les
opérateurs financiers les spécialistes
des marchés
eh ben ils ont pris conscience qu'il y
avait un problème avec le coronavirus
que l'économie chinoise
elle était quasiment à l'arrêt on le
savait on le savait depuis la fin du
mois de janvier
mais là ils en ont pris réellement
conscience qu'il a fallu pour cela qu'il
y ait cette fameuse statistique qui est
tombé le 20 février
les la consommation d'énergie en chine
est à 38 % 38 % seulement du niveau
qu'elle était l'année dernière
alors évidemment ça eu des désaccords
extrêmement 1% sur l' indice du 4k rock
qui s'est effondré rapidement qui au
début de la semaine est un type remonter
mais qui depuis jeudi est en train là
encore de rebaisser il y a un le dow
jones qui suit grosso modo le même
chemin le dow jones qui était au delà de
29500 donc un plus haut historique et
qui chute très brutalement avant de
repartir à la hausse mais de rechuter
encore un petit peu après et donc là on
voit bien qu'il ya un problème sérieux
alors jacques comment cela
s'explique-t-il
je voulais dire c'est en fait des
opérateurs qui vivent dans une forme de
déni de réalité qui considère que bon
quand on a un virus
oui ça existe mais ça n'aura pas de
conséquences économiques et qui tout
d'un coup comprennent que ben voilà avec
l'économie chinoise à l'arrêt ça ne peut
qu'avoir des conséquences économiques
extrêmement importante
alors ce phénomène est-il limité aux
seuls indices boursiers non non il ya
évidemment la question des matières
premières vous savez quand une économie
est quasiment à l'arrêt nous disons à 20
% de sa capacité de production normal et
bien évidemment elle achète beaucoup
moins de matière première et ça se voit
sur les cours du pétrole
voyez là on appris lundi du baril de
brent
alors le baril de brent il était monté
il ya un mois à peu près autour de 64 65
dollars pour un baril il est tombé
depuis là le milieu de cette semaine
grosso modo entre 49 et 50 de là c'est
très important parce que ça aussi un
impact sur je dirais la solvabilité de
toutes les entreprises américaines qui
exploite le pétrole de schiste mais
alors jacques
qu'est ce qui explique cette
sous-estimation jusqu'ici de l'impact du
corps navire
fondamentalement les opérateurs
financiers même chose pour les
gouvernements bailleurs n'ont pas
compris que le poids des économies
avaient fortement changé depuis 2003 en
2003 la chine ne peser que huit et demi
pour cent du pib mondial
les etats unis s'étaient 20% et on avait
un reste du monde qui était pratiquement
à 60% aujourd'hui plus exactement en
2019 eh bien on à la chine qui est à
plus de 19%
les etats-unis qui ne sont qu'à 15% la
chine est bien passé devant les états
unis mais ça se fait aussi au détriment
du reste du monde parce qu'il ya
d'autres pays un qui progresse comme
l'un est donc cela renforce
là je dirais le caractère central de
l'économie chinoise
alors est-ce qu'on va considérer dans
ces conditions que la france va être
touché
ah oui il est tout à fait évident qu'il
va y avoir des conséquences économiques
importantes sur la france alors pour
plusieurs raisons d'abord à la chine ne
peut plus fournir de pièces à assembler
à de nombreuses entreprises françaises
les clients chinois vont baisser leurs
achats en france ou en provenance de
france
on a aussi le problème du tourisme le
problème du transport aérien
mais il ya un autre problème c'est que
des économies comme l'économie allemande
l'économie italienne qui vendait
beaucoup en chine elle aussi elle se
retrouve là avec un impact très sévère
de cette crise or nous avons des
relations économiques extrêmement
intense avec ces pays l'allemagne est
traditionnellement notre premier
partenaire
donc si nos partenaires sont malades
on ne peut pas aller bien nous mêmes et
il est intéressant de voir que l' ocde a
fait à réviser plus exactement ses
prévisions alors que l' ocde prévoyait
une croissance de 1,2 pour cent pour
2020 aujourd'hui il ne prévoit plus que
0 9% et la question qu'on se pose
jacques quel va être l'impact réel sur
l'industrie française et européenne
alors
l'impact sera certainement important je
voulais parler évidemment de ces pièces
que l'on importe de chine
peut-être pour faire autre chose aussi
mais que l'on apporte de chaîner qu'on
ne peut plus avoir
mais vous savez il ya comme ça des
chiffres qui sont intéressantes prenons
le cas des matériels de construire des
matériels de transport dont les
importations directes de chine
c'est pas énorme c'est 1,6 milliard
d'euros
mais quand on regarde les importations
qui viennent des autres pays de l'union
européenne 60 milliards d'euros
là ça fait beaucoup ça fait grosso modo
3 % de notre produit intérieur brut dans
ces 60 milliards il ya 3 % de choses qui
sont produites en chine
autrement dit ce ne sont pas simplement
les importations chinoises qui vont
baisser qui veut qu'ils se sont réduites
mais c'est l'ensemble des chaînes de
production qui sont aujourd'hui touchés
y compris dans des pays qui pour
l'instant ne sont pas touchés par le
coronavirus je dis bien pour l'instant
parce que quand on voit ce qui se passe
en italie on comprend qu'il va y avoir
aussi des problèmes l'industrie italie
il faut le rappeler elle est
essentiellement en lombardie
alors jacques nous vous nous aviez parlé
il ya trois semaines on s'en souvient
des médicaments qu'en est il oui tout le
monde je sais aujourd'hui entre 60 et
80% des principes actifs des médicaments
sont produits que ce soit en chine où
que ce soit en un ce qui d'ailleurs pose
un véritable problème de souveraineté
pharmaceutique à la france
il est clair là que l'arrêt ou disons le
très fort ralentissement de la
production chinoise va avoir un impact
mais par ailleurs regardez cette courbe
elle est très intéressant il s'agit des
importations chinoises en produits
pharmaceutiques en matériels de
transport en 2005
grosso modo au moment de l'épidémie du
strass et bien il y avait entre 75 76 %
de la valeur qui étaient faites en chine
donc ce qu'il a dit qu'il y avait contre
2 25% qui était fait à l'étranger hors
de chine
aujourd'hui on est à 85%
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que non seulement les produits chinois
sont importants dans les importations
que nous achetons hors de chine par
exemple dans l'union européenne aux
états unis mais que les produits chinois
eux mêmes quand nous avons des
importations directes de la chine
devienne entre guillemets de plus en
plus chinois et ça c'est un très bon
indicateur justement de ce poids de la
chine alors jacques vous nous dresser un
quand même un tableau particulièrement
sombre à un peu plus on vend même il
faut bien le dire va-t-on comme on se le
demande de plus en plus vers un remake
de la grande crise de 2008 selon vo
alors d'abord il s'agit pas d'être
pessimiste ou optimiste et gilles
simplement d'être réaliste alors oui le
problème de ce qui se passe sur les
marchés financiers il est sérieux il est
sérieux pourquoi parce que ça veut dire
que la des entreprises des banques aussi
peuvent connaître des gros problèmes de
liquidités d'ores et déjà les banques
françaises ont été très durement attaqué
en milieu de semaine et donc ça veut
dire qu'il faudra qu'il y ait une action
spécifique des banques centrales pour
les soutenir
au-delà de cette action des banques
centrales parce qu'on va très vite voir
que les banques centrales ne peuvent pas
tout faire
vous savez la réserve fédérale
américaine elle a baissé son taux
directeur de 0 5% autour ni de 50 points
maintenant qu'est ce qu'elle peut faire
elle peut encore le baisser de nouveau
50 ans et puis elle sera à zéro
elle va payer les gens pour que le pour
leur prêter oui bien il ya un véritable
problème
même chose avec la bce donc ça veut dire
que aujourd'hui les capacités d'action
des banques centrales sont en réalité
pour une réduite que ce qu'elle était à
la veille de la crise de 2008
et c'est ça justement l'un des soucis
que l'on a
si on a la combinaison d'une crise dans
la production à laquelle les banques
centrales ne peuvent rien mais aussi de
problèmes alors par exemple bancaire
vous allez avoir plein d'entreprises qui
comme elles ne produisent plus comme
elles ne vendent plus ne pourront pas
rembourser leurs emprunts ne pourront
pas payer leurs intérêts donc si on a la
combinaison de ce problème réel et de ce
problème financier
il se pourrait bien
que le coronavirus provoque en réalité
une crise du même ordre que ce la crise
de 2008 et on peut dire si vous voulez
que autant la crise de 2008 c'était la
crise de la finance globalisée
c'était parti de titres pourris
américain autant là la crise du
coronavirus c'est la véritable crise de
la mondialisation
merci jacques je sais pas si je dois
vous remercier d'ailleurs aujourd'hui de
nous avoir plombé notre moral merci je
suis désolé en tout cas ça donne à
réfléchir à très bientôt j'espère